car nous avons besoin aussi d'être en
paix et en harmonie
[Musique]
sans surprise donald trump a été
officiellement investi par son parti
lors de la présidentielle de novembre
une convention qui s'est ouvert ce lundi
à charlotte en caroline du nord
en retard dans les sondages face à joe
biden à l'actuel président américain
entend bien défendre son bilan en vue
d'une victoire déjouant les pronostics
la visite de mike pompéo à jérusalem où
il rencontre le premier ministre
israélien au coeur des discussions
l'accord de normalisation entre l'état
hébreu et les émirats arabes unis
annoncé il y a dix jours ça d'accord
pour l'instant sur une transition
politique au mali entre les envoyés de
la cedeao et limitèrent insurgés selon
ces derniers le retour d'ibrahim
boubacar kéita au pouvoir est d'ores et
déjà exclue
le président déchu a fait savoir qu'il
ne souhaitait plus gouverner son pays
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
si vous nous rejoignez donald trump a
donc été officiellement investi par le
parti républicain comme candidat à sa
réélection lors de la présidentielle du
3 novembre
sans surprise les 330 représentant
républicain des 50 états ont désigné le
président comme leur candidat au premier
jour de la convention du parti
l'occasion pour lui de relancer sa
campagne alors qu'il affiche un retard
dans les sondages face à son rival joe
biden un événement qui intervient alors
que la ville a été le théâtre cette nuit
de heurts entre forces de l'ordre et
manifestants
ces derniers protester contre ce
rendez-vous républicain et cette
question donald trump ou réty d'être
réélu président le système de vote
américain par collège électoral avait
déjà créé la surprise en 2016 lorsque
l'homme d'affaires n'avait emporté face
à hillary clinton malgré une large
avance de cette dernière kirill kotick
of il ya quatre ans cela avait été la
grosse surprise donald trump était élu
président des états unis alors que
l'immense majorité des médias et des
instituts de sondage
tout le monde en fait le donnait
perdants mais quatre ans plus tard alors
que les présidentielles américaines
approchent à grands pas on sent que les
sondeurs sont beaucoup plus prudent
lorsqu'il s'agit de prédire l'élection
comme s'ils avaient retenu la leçon
et pour cause le contexte n'est plus le
même qu'en 2016 les états unis ont
accumulé les problèmes internes en
particulier en 2020 crise sanitaire sans
précédent crise économique d'ampleur des
manifestations contre le racisme qui
dégénère et vire au pillage un festival
de violences policières
dans un tel contexte difficile de
prédire la réaction de la population
globalement les médias et les
observateurs s'obstine à considérer la
défaite de trump comme une évidence les
grandes villes comme new york ou los
angeles ont presque tout démocrate
la cote de popularité de trump n'est pas
à son plus haut niveau 40 % environ et
la récente polémique impliquant le
président sortant accusé de vouloir
détruire la poste américaine pour
empêcher le vote par correspondance qui
pourrait jouer en sa défaveur viennent
ternir les ambitions républicaine sauf
qu aux etats unis ce n'est pas le nombre
de vote au niveau national qui définit
l'élection mais le collège électoral
les citoyens américains élisent ce
qu'ils vont élire leur président et là
il ya moyen de se faire avoir comme il
ya quatre ans lorsque hillary clinton
attendue
grande gagnante avait perdu le collège
électoral alors qu'elle avait presque 3
millions de voix d'avancé sur troyes 2
170 délégués suffisent pour remporter la
victoire même si joe biden est
actuellement en tête dans les sondages
et dans de nombreux états clés d action
républicaine pouvant retourner la
situation reste possible comme par
exemple une relance économique post
coronavirus l'annoncent d'un vaccin
contre le kobe 19 la grâce des douars
snowden peut-être qui sait ce que le
camp républicain réserve
en tout cas le camp présidentiel est
loin de se laisser intimider par
quelques sondages prédictions donald
trump est officiellement le candidat
républicain pour la présidentielle de
novembre
nous avons besoin de remporter soit le
wiz consignes soient le michigan soit la
pennsylvanie pour gagner de nouveau si
nous gagnons l'un de ces trois états et
les étapes que le président a remporté
en 2016
joe biden va rester dans son sous sol
attendons donc de tuer l'ours avant de
vendre sa peau et pour pierre guerlain
professeur de civilisation américaine le
chemin est encore long jusqu'à la
présidentielle selon lui il faut se
méfier de potentiel d'affaires qui
pourrait être révélée en octobre les
sondages certes disent qu'il est élu
davis mais on ne sait pas ce qui va se
passer il ya une expression aux états
unis qui est la surprise d'octobre il
est possible en octobre
un des deux candidats ou les deux
candidats sortent une affaire très
importante qui dont l'objectif sera de
changer l'opinion d'une grande partie de
la population donc il faut faire très
attention
déjà très bas s'est présenté comme
l'artisan de l'accord entre israël les
les états arabes unis donc il essaie de
regagner du crédit
en politique étrangère il est possible
que les démocrates et une information
catastrophique est vague et on sortir en
octobre
donc il faut vraiment se méfier
actuellement le la gestion du coït qui
effectivement très mauvaise états unis
sens plutôt militer pour une défaite de
temps
et les chiffres s'améliorent légèrement
pour le coc guide
il est chauve à 40% n'a toujours pas
dévisser donc il faut faire très
attention effectivement pompé au est
actuellement à jérusalem où il rencontre
le premier ministre israélien pour
parler de l'accord de normalisation
entre l'état hébreu et des émirats
arabes unis énoncé il y a dix jours
le secrétaire d'état américain se dit
optimiste de voir d'autres pays arabes
normaliser leurs relations avec l'état
hébreu
de son côté benyamin netanyahu assure
que son pays est à l'écouté des pays du
golfe lors de la suite de mon voyage je
suis très optimiste de voir d'autres
pays arabes se rallier à cette
opportunité l'opportunité pour eux de
travailler avec l'état reconnues
d'israël
cela permettra non seulement d'accroître
la stabilité du moyen-orient mais aussi
d'améliorer la vie des habitants de leur
propre pays il est important de
souligner qu'aujourd'hui nous entendons
les pays du golfe et les pays du golfe
peuvent s'exprimer avec autant de force
que je le fais maintenant et je pense
que je suggérerais à nos amis en
particulier à nos amis européens
cette pensée lorsque les arabes et les
israéliens s'entendent sur quelque chose
il est logique d'y prêter attention une
normalisation qui pourrait profiter aux
etats unis puisque washington compte sur
ce rapprochement pour faire avancer un
dossier sensible la vente de ses avions
de combat f-35 aux émirats arabes unis
les précisions de clément hospital
l'avion de chasse américain f 35
pourrait-il être à l'origine de l'accord
entre les émirats arabes unis et israël
c'est une thèse évoquée depuis que le
deal a été conclu sous la houlette des
états unis et qui est éminemment
sensible car washington garantie à
israël la primauté au moyen-orient de
l'accès au matériel militaire américain
de pointe ce qui assure l état hébreu
d'être le mieux armé de la région
benyamin nétanyahou a précisé ce lundi
que l'accord conclu avec abou dhabi n'a
qu ait pas de clause concernant le f 35
en précisant avoir reçu des garanties
des états unis sur le maintien de son
avantage stratégique au moyen-orient
le secrétaire d'état américain nike
pompéo qui entame d'ailleurs une tournée
au moyen-orient
confiants les dires du premier ministre
israélien mais n'exclut pas une
ouverture à d'autres pays arabes
nous avons des relations sécuritaires
avec les émirats arabes unis depuis plus
de 20 ans et nous leur avons également
fourni une assistance technique et
militaire
nous allons maintenant poursuivre
l'examen de ce processus pour nous
assurer qu'ils nous leur fournissons un
équipement dont ils ont besoin pour
sécuriser défendre leur propre
population contre cette même menace que
représente la république islamique
d'iran
de son côté le ministre des affaires
étrangères des émirats
anwar gargash indiqué récemment au
groupe de réflexion atlantic council que
la chatte d'armes à washington dont des
avions de combat f 35 était tout à fait
possible elle l'achat d'armement est
quelque chose qui est sur la table
nous avons des demandes légitimes qui
sont là nous devons les obtenir
à mon avis maintenant tout l'idée d'un
état de belligérance ou de guerre avec
israël n'existe plus quoi qu'il en soit
l'accord conclu entre l'état hébreu et
les émirats arabes unis pourrait
accélérer la course aux armements dans
la région
les spéculations vont d'ailleurs bon
train sur les prochains candidats
possibles à une normalisation avec
israël comme le bahreïn oman ou encore
le soudan 1 pour jacques benillouche un
journaliste indépendant en israël mike
pompéo vient avant tout pour apaiser
l'inquiétude des dirigeants du pays
je pense que mike pompéo est venu
prévenir les risques
bien disons faire son mea culpa auprès
des israéliens pour les chèques qu'il a
eu à l'onu et au conseil de sécurité
parce qu'il n'a pas réussi à obtenir la
prolongation des sanctions à merveille
et américaines contre l'iran est la même
pas pu obtenir l'arrêt de l'accord d'une
sanctions unilatérales des américains
contre lui donc il est venu ici déjà aux
en israël pour calmer le jeu parce que
cette information est doublée d'une
autre information dont on parle peu
c'est le lancement récent d'amélie du
d'un missile balistique qui a été
d'ailleurs appelé le missile sur les
mamies lune ont dû du chef du groupe el
qods qui a été éliminé par les amériques
ado qu'il est venu pour calmer le jeu
avant une visite en russie le secrétaire
d'état adjoint américain est
actuellement lituanie pour discuter de
la situation en biélorussie voilà deux
semaines que le pays est secoué par des
manifestations quotidiennes contre le
pouvoir en place
après avoir rencontrer l'opposante fait
la nati canaux sky à stéphane begun a
jugé que l'on sent les pays devraient
respecter le choix du peuple biélorusse
nous condamnons la violation des droits
de l'homme et la brutalité que nous
avons vu en biélorussie depuis les
élections et nous appelons le
gouvernement de biélorussie à libérer
tous les prisonniers politiques qu'il
détient actuellement nous pensons qu'il
existe une solution qui peut être
acceptable pour tout le monde mais en
fin de compte bien sur elle c'est au
peuple biélorusse de faire son propre
choix
nous la lituanie et la russie devons
tous respecter le choix du peuple
biélorusse la contestation contre la
réélection d'alexandre loukachenko se
poursuit donc le kremlin se dit
préoccupé par la situation
les lumières poutine a eu aujourd'hui un
entretien téléphonique avec le président
biélorusse chef de la diplomatie
allemande a de son côté appelé au
dialogue
le point avec des villes d'oyse inouïe
une démonstration de force
au soir d'une nouvelle mobilisation
massive contre lui une vidéo diffusée
par le gouvernement montrent le
président biélorusse alexandre
loukachenko poser en gilet pare-balles
fusil d'assaut à la main alors qu'il
descend d'un hélicoptère après avoir
survolé le lieu où ces opposants
s'étaient mobilisés en masse à minsk
après ses 26 ans de règne
les contestataires veulent du changement
pour leur pays
[Musique]
je veux que notre pays vivent dans la
joie et la liberté
comme tout pays civilisé c'est pour ça
que je suis là il y a plus de monde ici
aujourd'hui que le week-end dernier
les gens viennent ils sentent que le
pouvoir est dans notre camp les ouvriers
les gens ordinaires aussi ils nous ont
aussi rejoint petit à petit ceux qui ne
peuvent pas sortir dans la rue comme les
enfants et les personnes âgées
ils suivent de près ce qu'il se passe
ils sont soucieux c'est une question
d'honneur chaque personne vient pour la
liberté la nôtre est la vôtre
pour tous ceux qui ont été enfermés
comme prisonniers politiques pour tous
ceux qui ont été tabassés sont toujours
portées disparues on descend dans la rue
pour défendre notre position pour
défendre notre choix et pour enfin avoir
un nouveau président
les ya des contestations qui interpelle
également à l'étranger
en déplacement en ukraine le chef de la
diplomatie allemande
et comme as a appelé le président
loukachenko acceptait le dialogue pour
régler une situation critique
je pense que loukachenko voit que ces
dernières semaines les russes se sont
remplis de manifestants c'est pourquoi
nous appelons à ne pas recourir à la
violence
directeur des monstres et à respecter
les droits des manifestants
le kremlin se dit également préoccupé
mais invite cependant les biélorusses à
gérer leurs problèmes eux mêmes afin
d'éviter toute ingérence
nous sommes effectivement toujours
préoccupé par certaines manifestations
directs et indirects d' ingérence
extérieure dans les affaires internes de
la biélorussie nous considérons que
c'est inacceptable et appelons toutes
les parties à laisser les biélorusses
régler leurs problèmes eux mêmes
toujours selon moscou une réforme
constitutionnelle pourrait être une
solution durable à la crise politique
qui agite le pays
de son côté alexandre loukachenko a
affirmé n'avoir besoin d'aucune aide
extérieure pour faire face à la
situation dans son pays
l opposant russe alexeï navalni présente
des traces d'empoisonnement selon
l'hôpital allemand où il a été admis
dans le coma une version qui contredit
celle des médecins qui l'ont examiné en
russie ont fait le point depuis moscou
avec notre correspondant en toile
claireaux l'hôpital berlinois dans
lequel a été prise en charge
alexeï navalni a publié dans
l'après-midi un communiqué qui évoque la
présence dans son organisme d'une
substance toxique une substance de la
famille des inhibiteurs de la colline
estérase qui s'attaque au système
nerveux substance en elle-même n'a pas
encore été identifié les analyses
continue cependant d'après les médecins
allemands des séquelles à long terme ne
peuvent être exclues à ce stade et la
chancelière allemande a réagi en
appelant la russie
à punir les coupables plus tôt dans la
journée déjà le gouvernement allemand
avait fait savoir qu'il jugeait da c'est
probable la thèse de l'empoisonnement
attentionné le soupçon ne porte pas sur
le fait que monsieur n'à vanille s'est
gravement empoisonnés lui-même mais sur
le fait que quelqu'un est gravement
empoisonnés monsieur n'à vanille et
malheureusement il existe un ou deux
exemples de ce genre dans l'histoire
récente de la réussite c'est pourquoi je
pense que le monde entier prend ce
soupçon très au sérieux
mais voilà ses conclusions dans
l'hôpital allemand viennent contredire
les déclarations tenues pas plus tard
que ce matin par le directeur de
l'hôpital d'omsk dans lequel a été prise
en charge
alexeï navalni dans un premier temps le
diagnostic d'empoisonnement a été
maintenu jusqu'à la fin de la journée
jusqu'à minuit si je ne me trompe pas
nous avons alors reçu la conclusion
finale de deux laboratoires à tomsk et à
moscou qu'aucun produit chimique toxique
pouvant être considéré comme un poison
ou un dérivé de poison n'a été trouvé
depuis le ministère de la santé d'omsk a
proposé de communiquer à l'hôpital de
berlin l'ensemble des résultats des
analyses menées par les médecins et ce
ne sera pas de trop pour répondre aux
questions encore nombreuse qui continue
de planer sur cette affaire au mali
toujours pas d'accord après trois jours
de pourparlers entre les représentants
de la communauté économique des états
d'afrique de l'ouest et les militaires
au pouvoir
selon les dernières informations ibrahim
boubacar keita a confié ne plus vouloir
diriger son pays le porte parole des
militaires insurgés annoncé ce soir que
le président déchu pourra choisir son
lieu de résidence et quitter le pays
pour des raisons médicales à l'issue de
pourparlers avec les membres de la
cedeao
donc c'est pour l'éducation a été
acceptée donc il peut être sécurisés
dans un endroit de son choix
il pourra aller se soigner et revenir
quand il veut la cedeao a donné son
point de vue par rapport à leur concept
de transition nous aussi on a discuté
par rapport à ce que nous on pensait de
la position il ya des discussions de
part et d'autre sacha qu'à ce stade rien
n'est arrêté
rien n'est décidé et que nous à notre
niveau
l'architecte yves finale de la
transition sera discutée défini entre
nous
retour en images sur une semaine
politique mouvementée à bamako
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour mamadou cissé président du
conseil national de la jeunesse malienne
de france la transition de trois ans
assurées par des militaires fera l'objet
de débats dans les jours à venir
certains trouvent les trois ans c'est
beaucoup
la poser la question de savoir si c'est
suffisant je pense que les maliens sont
peut-être pas préparé à ça d'ailleurs
dès la déclaration de du porte-parole
laissé entendre que ça l'aide d'une
courte durée les trois années paraît
beaucoup déjà à certains maliens même si
d'opinions assez divisés certains disent
qu'il faut vraiment une vraie réforme de
l'état malien
et pour cela il faut un peu plus de
temps maintenant cette transition elle
était censée être dirigé par des civils
ne fait que et une fuite parce que ça
n'est pas encore officielle n'a pas
encore été communiqué officiel les fait
qu'il ya une fuite pour dire que ce sera
la transition sera dirigée par un
militaire je pense que ce sera la
question va poser des bas dans les jours
à venir
après l'annoncé d'un cessez le feu
vendredi dernier et l'organisation
prochaine d'élections le calme n'est pas
revenu en libye des centaines de
manifestants étaient dans les rues de la
capitale tripoli hier leur but dénoncer
les conditions de vie de plus en plus
difficile et la corruption dans le pays
cette manifestation a été dispersée
lorsque les protestataires sont arrivés
sur la place des martyrs la manul la
mission d'appui des nations unies en
libye rapportent plusieurs blessés
l'onu appelle de son côté le
gouvernement libyen d'union nationale à
une enquête immédiate et gèle l archet
oui chercheur à l'institut glen la clean
des labels pardon de là et nous explique
pourquoi selon lui le cessez le feu est
difficile à mettre en place en libye à
cause du nombre d'acteurs internationaux
déjà deux parce que cela est aussi
l'imbrication extrêmement étroite entre
le caractère économique de la crise et
le caractère militaire et un civil est
aujourd'hui beaucoup moins
conventionnelle que pendant la première
moitié de 2020
le moyen d'expression du maréchal haftar
c'est d'abord avant tout le blocus
pétroliers c'est ce qui lui permet
d'être anglais la capitale tripoli
mais aussi par la même occasion ensemble
du pays mais il ya donc une la gamine à
camille vient aussi avec un retour des
vieilles lignes de fractures notamment
toujours dans tripolitaine dans la zone
qui est censé être contrôlé par le
gouvernement de tripoli
il ya de vieilles rancunes qui
aujourd'hui peuvent s'exprimer plus
facilement que pendant la période de
neuf ans yves de la part du maréchal
tard dans la zone de tripoli une
offensive qui a été interrompue et
cassée début juin 2020 la crise du
coronavirus 1955 nouveaux cas confirmés
au commis 19 en france ces dernières 24
heures contre 4897 nouveaux cas hier des
chiffres en baisse pour la première fois
depuis mi août le nom d'hospitalisations
est en légère baisse également
contrairement au nom de cas graves qui
lui augmente légèrement avec 399 me l'a
toujours en réanimation
sachez également que 18 nouveaux foyers
ont été découverts depuis hier le
gouvernement n'anticipe pas assez les
hôpitaux pourraient manquer
d'équipements en cas de nouveaux pics
épidémiques c'est ce que pense thierry
amouroux porte-parole du syndicat
d'infirmiers c'est ce qui nous inquiète
c'est la tension que l'on constate sur
le matériel dont on a besoin pour faire
faire les soins
c'est à dire que si on a assez de
masques chirurgicaux
on manque que toute offre de masques
ffp2 il ya des tensions sur les gants
médicaux sur les sur blues
alors que on est trois mois après une
baisse
de l'activité qu'ovide ce qui veut dire
que si on se retrouve face à un nouveau
pic que ce soit une deuxième vague ou un
rebond on va vite à être à court de
matériel de protection donc ça on est
particulièrement inquiet parce que le
gouvernement est toujours en retard
n'est pas dans l'anticipation et on
risque de se retrouver que des sacs
poubelles sur le dos comme il ya
quelques mois et c'est dans ce contexte
qu'est manuel maquereau et le
gouvernement aborde cette semaine une
rentrée particulièrement délicate
l'impératif est de maîtriser la reprise
de l'épidémie afin qu'elle ne menace pas
la relance économique
l'autre priorité de l'exécutif cécilia
chaud c'est une rentrée à hauts risques
pour jean castex pourtant très présent
sur le terrain cet été avec 16
déplacements rien qu'en juillet le
nouveau premier ministre est rattrapée
par les effets de la crise sanitaire
selon le dernier baromètre ifop pour le
jdd il ne recueille que 48% d'opinions
favorables une baisse de 7 points par
rapport à début juillet dans le même
temps 46% des personnes interrogées le
désapprouvent aujourd'hui un chiffre en
hausse
emmanuel macron lui a fixé son cap pour
la rentrée
vivre avec le virus mais sans mettre le
pays à l'arrêt autrement dit sans
affaiblir davantage l'économie mardi le
chef de l'état a prévu un conseil de
défense pour faire le point sur
l'évolution de l'épidémie et sur sa
gestion
les mesures de précaution sanitaires
dans les établissements scolaires les
entreprises et les transports en
particulier au centre de toutes les
attentions devrait être annoncé à la
sortie du premier conseil des ministres
de rentrée mercredi la question du port
du masque obligatoire dans les collèges
les 10
les entreprises à compter du 1er
septembre et déjà l'occasion pour le
monde politique de prendre position avec
en ligne de mire la présidentielle de
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour nombre d'observateurs cette rentrée
2020 exceptionnel du fait de la crise
sanitaire fera figure de test pour les
deux dernières années du quinquennat est
le gouvernement met au même niveau ou
l'urgence sanitaire et l'urgence
économique c'est ce qu'a assuré ce matin
le ministre de l'économie sur rtl alors
que le plan de relance de l'économie a
été décalée d'une semaine un report qui
ne change rien assure bruno le maire le
plan prévoit une enveloppe de 100
milliards d'euros dont 40 milliards
écouter le décryptage de notre
chroniqueur économique jean marc
sylvestre
quand on écoute les chefs d'entreprise
ou les syndicats ça l'ait jamais
suffisant mais assez 100 milliards qui
se compose de 40 milliards pour la
réindustrialisation 1,20 milliard pour
la transition écologique 20 milliards
pour l'emploi 20 milliards aussi pour la
solidarité nationale
au total donc 100 milliards qui vont
arriver après les plus de 400 milliards
qui ont été mobilisés en début de crise
un an en mars donc l'effort global pour
éviter l'écroulement la suite si
complète du système économique français
a quand même été important il est à la
hauteur d'ailleurs de ce qu'a fait
l'allemagne ou même les états unis
je crois que le gouvernement l'a fait
pour des raisons de calendrier politique
et de communication il faut d'abord
régler
on l'a bien vu la question de la rentrée
scolaire est assez compliqué il faut
ensuite être sûr que les mesures de
protection renforcée contre le virus
seront à accepter par les personnels
d'entreprises quand on voit ce qui s'est
passé hier
c'est pas évident le masque dans
l'entreprise il est mal supporté elle
est d'ailleurs mal supporté par tout le
monde au fonds le gouvernement reste
très hésitant parce que les informations
qu'on a sur l'épidémie sont encore très
flou très anxiogène
on ne sait pas final évidemment s'il va
se passer alors la peur est très
présente c'est une épée de damoclès la
peur est plus dangereuse que le virus
lui même aujourd'hui donc
le gouvernement cherche la formule qui
pourrait rassurer
pour l'instant il n'a pas encore trouvé
c'est la fin de ce journal merci de
l'avoir suivi on se retrouve dans 30
minutes pour une nouvelle édition
[Musique]
l'écologie ce n'est pas de la politique
johnny rapport du giec sur les océans
comme ça